hey youtubers is Charlie so I've already
done a couple spider-man homecoming
videos about the characters that they've
cast they've started filming now in the
reason you're seeing James Gunn with Tom
Holland and Chris Pratt is because
they're filming in the same area where
they film guardians of the galaxy one of
the bigger producers behind the
spider-man franchise at Sony actually
said something really cool it just
confirmed some of the things that people
have been talking about with Marvel and
Sony sharing the character so what he
said is is that Marvel has creative lead
sony has greenlight so when we say
spider-man is part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe it's true in the
deepest sense Marvel is making all the
creative decisions about what the
character does what everything looks
like the tone of the film Sony just has
the ability to thumbs-up thumbs-down so
when they say they have green light that
means that if Marvel wanted a particular
character that Sony didn't want in their
film they could say no or they wanted a
particular actor Sony could say no they
still have to sign off on everything but
largely all the ideas are flowing from
Marvel so it really is a Marvel film and
actually much bigger way than I had
thought before before this I thought it
was a bit more of a collaboration behind
the scenes like Sony had people coming
up with ideas Marvel had people coming
up with ideas and they just decided to
go with the best one but really it's
Marvel doing all the cooking and Sony
just giving up high fives for being so
awesome which i think is great even
though the actual terms of the agreement
a relatively secret but it seems like is
happening is that they're going to
continue this relationship through at
least both of the Avengers films that
spider-man is going to be featured in
that's infinity war spider-man will be
part of infinity war on the other side
of that MCU characters will cameo in the
new spider-man films so I think they'll
continue that relationship at least
through both Avengers films and probably
through the third new spider-man film
because even though they're just making
spider-man homecoming right now it's
really going to be a trilogy which
assuming they make a new one every two
years would take at least six more years
so that's through both Avengers films
and then just like a little bit more for
that last spider-man film then after
that all bets are off so we're talking
all the way through phase 3 of Marvel in
probably a little bit of phase 4
so around Captain Marvel time I'm sure
you'll hear more stuff about new
spider-man films or if Tom Hollands
going to continue to be spider-man which
hopefully he does hopefully everything
goes really well and you don't want to
see him leave it's like Robert Downey
jr. and Iron Man like oh my god nobody
else can be Iron Man you were the only
person who can play this character
because we're talking about billions of
dollars between these two mega companies
making all these movies obviously
they're going to reevaluate their
relationship after each film depending
on its success and I do think that
spider-man homecoming will be the most
profitable film in the franchise's
history mostly because of all this
spider-man Avengers fanfare like just
sharing the character is such a big deal
it's such a big time in the characters
history in the movies I think regardless
of what the film ends up being it will
still be its most profitable we'll be so
curious to see what it looks like but
because these are going to be Marvel
films you know whatever idea is that
they're creating in this first
spider-man film expect some of that to
trickle down to the other two sequels
the only thing we really know about the
other spider-man films they're planning
on making just because they're so far
off is that they will follow Peter
Parker through high school like he'll
remain a high school character through
both Avengers films so what is the
difference between a Marvel spider-man
film in a Sony spider-man film the
biggest difference I think is in the
conception just the idea of a high
school kid played by a very young actor
a very young version of the character
and the tone is much more in keeping
with the tone of films in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe so think about the
way civil war kind of pulled at your
heartstrings a little bit there was a
lot of Joe keenest but there was also a
lot of emotion really the most important
spider-man scene in civil war is not the
airport fight it's actually the scene
where he meets Tony Stark for the first
time in their apartment and he explains
to him who he is in why he wants to be a
hero where he and Tony Stark are just
talking to each other back and forth
just like normal people but they're both
these crazy superheroes talking about
very human emotions and that's one of
the hardest parts to nail and Marvel
does it so well has just been doing it
for so long so successfully that I think
he knows exactly the moments that it's
looking for in films in Tom Hall and
himself like the actor can't say enough
about him when he's in these scenes with
Robert Downey jr. just completely nails
the Peter Parker character he's really
like one of the few people that can out
quit Tony Stark in the comics so that's
really where you're seeing Marvel's
influence in the way the dialogue is
written as opposed to say like Tobey
Maguire's version of spider-man which is
a great film like that original
spider-man film was so special but Tobey
Maguire's version of the character is
just so introverted and that is not
spider-man at all there's that scene
where
says you know there's not this much
talking in a fight and spider-mans like
oh I'm sorry I didn't realize that's
such a great example of like a 15 16
year old spider-man just a kid who
absolutely has no idea what's going on
mr. stark what am I supposed to do just
web them up kid Web them up
he stops Winter Soldier dead in his
tracks that whole scene was just to show
you how strong he is just like it's no
big deal so what a perfect introduction
that was like you get the tone of the
Peter Parker character when he's with
Tony Stark really like the most
important part of the character then you
get all the cool stuff in the airport
scene without them throwing away the
little kid that's inside the mask I
think if anything making him sound that
innocent and inexperienced just makes it
seem more authentic so of course a
teenage version of spider-man is going
to have that kind of insecurity and
inexperience when he's fighting
criminals like this will all be fine I'm
just gonna bumble my way through this in
a hilarious way let me know what you
guys think about the idea of a teenage
Marvel film we really haven't had any
teenage superheroes all the other
Avengers are adults even vision who was
born yesterday is something of an adult
like you know Paul Bettany could not be
a teenager if he tried so the first
thing you notice when you go to see this
new spider-man film is just how young
the character is if you go back and you
watch like that Tobey Maguire spider-man
film where he's in high school you have
James Franco like they still look like
they're in their late 20s so you
definitely feel like it's adults playing
kids instead of a kid playing a kid so
awesome on Marvel for finding someone so
young that could pull off Peter Parker
so well and don't you just wonder in
this picture here what is on the mixtape
that they gave to spider-man music is
actually a really important part of the
movie that I haven't talked about like
the rhythm of the character the score of
the new spider-man film will set the
tone of that we don't know what that's
going to be I'm actually really curious
to see what the new theme song for
spider-man is because Danny Elfman like
the original spider-man theme that he
wrote for that first Tobey Maguire film
is still one of my favorite superhero
movie songs of all time his spider-man
theme was kind of like the John Williams
Superman theme for the Richard Donner
Superman films you just remember it
instantly wherever you're hear it so
I'll be interested to see what they do
for this new spider-man film but in
related news I'm going to be doing
another Civil War video tonight before I
head down to VidCon it'll be relatively
Hulk related there's been a whole bunch
of WTF hulks
stuff happening in the comics right now
they started to explain what's going on
with Bruce Banner in the comics Bruce
Banner isn't the Hulk right now
Amadeus Cho has all of his powers so
I'll explain whatever I post that video
be sure to subscribe to get it
and if any of you guys are going to be
at VidCon I'll be down there on Friday
and Saturday I will be making videos
still so I'll be making videos from
VidCon but if you do see me feel free to
say hi it's going to be a lot of fun
while you guys wait for that next video
to post you can click here to learn more
about what's going on with spider-man
homecoming and you can click here for my
Game of Thrones Q&A from this week thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you